the absolute worst thing that could
happen as I'm wearing a skirt is me
flashing someone and my underwear and my
penis not being has aligned as they
should be
I can't remember but honestly I probably
did wear a skirt when I was younger
sometimes up pants are a little bit
restricting I'm kind of excited to get
in there and it breezy I don't really
think that I have a very sexy lower body
so opening myself up like this it's
gonna be quite interesting
my personal goal is to become more
confident with my body I'm not sure
about this color this is very short I
don't think this is what we discussed
I love blues I love White's perfect
I don't think anyone really told me how
hard it would be to hide my penis these
things are not very functional I have to
figure out other ways to carry things
around without pockets why do you think
I won't be able to handle it because you
always sit like this Edgar you can't do
that mistake look at him look at him
look at improper form right there I
personally feel like I look good in this
outfit but I still feel self-conscious
wearing it I think the hardest part
about this is I'm not sure if I'm
matching I don't know if this shirt goes
with the skirt it took me one really
good I just got a home from work and
there was this family walking by and so
I ran back into my car and I mean it's
totally weird because just earlier today
I was outside walking around in public
wearing this skirt with friends and I
was totally fine because I had them and
it kind of is stupid that I can't do
this by myself
I'm liking a lot of the walks down the
street are getting a little hard I feel
like I'm being stared at I mean I know
I'm wearing a skirt and that's why
they're looking but I I guess I kind of
underestimated how much it will kind of
affect me that's interesting that that
immediately if you're wearing something
that isn't considered your genders norm
that people get kind of weird about it
after the car incident my good friend
Shane gave me a little pep talk nobody
cares that you're wearing a skirt except
for you
life lessons so it's been about a week
now and to be honest I'm probably gonna
miss wearing a skirt um it's just been a
super great experience I really loved it
I will stopped on several occasions and
told dude I can see your penis so I
wasn't good at that part getting used to
no pockets was the thing so I ended up
having to carry a bag around with me it
took a little getting used to but I had
a lot of fun with getting into my
outfits looking good I am more in tune
with my body and I like am more
confident and I don't really care as
much about what people think now I
probably won't wear a skirt again it's
cuz I can't cross my legs that's the
only reason why I cross my legs I would
do it but I cannot I think guys can Rock
skirts I think anybody can rock it
anything and who's to tell you that
you're not if you're confident in what
you're wearing and you feel comfortable
in it then you are rocking it